foreign
businesses are going hand in hand these
days anyone looking for good growth in
their business tries to grab the
attention of the audiences with the
similar interest on the web for which
SEO plays an important role SEO
techniques are equally impactful for a
Google website or an Instagram post more
your content reaches the Right audience
the more likely you are to get the leads
and make business out of it because of
this SEO experts are in high demand in
this video on how to become an SEO
expert we will share the best tips to
become an SEO expert in a very short
period of time but before we begin
consider subscribing to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn so here is a
question for you when was SEO first used
option one in 1980s option two in 1970s
option 3 in 1990s an option 4 in 2010s
let us know your answer in the comment
section below and if your answer is
correct you will get a heart from Simply
learn so without any further Ado let's
start by understanding what Market holds
for professional SEO experts nowadays it
is very common to start a business by
having a website with the increase of
website there is always a need of
organic growth and there the SEO comes
into picture
it is important to have an SEO expert to
have a well SEO optimized website Market
is flourished with a ton of SEO jobs
from SEO executive to SEO manager all
the SEO job roles have high demand the
salary for various SEO roles is
estimated to reach as high as hundred
thousand dollars giants like coin switch
eBay havelet Packard in the industries
are ready to hire the candidates having
SEO expertise so without taking a minute
let's start with the pro tips on how to
become an SEO expert number one is
understanding the basics of content
creation and content optimization as it
is said content is the king to be an SEO
expert you need to be the best in
content creation search engines value
high quality content and promote it to
be on the top of search results creating
high quality content should be the
must-have quality of an SEO expert
effort although this is not enough once
you create a good content it is
necessary for the content to be well
optimized you should have a great
content strategies to spread the content
among the Right audience let's move to
our tip number two understanding SEO
basics
it is really important to understand the
basics to make the right decisions
having technical knowledge of SEO May
prevent you from making mistakes that
may harm your business directly or
indirectly say having right knowledge on
how on-page optimization Works will help
you to optimize your content or web
pages more efficiently thereby allowing
your content or web pages to rank higher
in search result page moving towards our
next tip which is how search engine
works
search engines are responsible for
listing the user search queries due to
which it becomes easier for search
engines to identify the content and
display the relevant results
search engines work on three basic steps
crawling indexing and ranking crawling
also known as web crawling involves
search engine Bots to crawl your web
content and pick up the hints or showing
what the web page is about with these
hints or here we can say important
keywords search engine Bots indexes your
web content into the web index once your
page is indexed it gets easily eligible
to appear in the search results if a
user enters the query and your content
matches the query it appears in the
search results moreover if your content
is really unique then you never know it
can also rank on the first position
coming to a tip number four
understanding and implementation of
technical aspects of SEO before moving
into this domain one should be aware of
technical aspects of SEO you should have
a good understanding on how a website
should actually be is the website
structure easy to understand if not then
how one can make it easy website
structure plays an important role for
search engine Bots if search engine Bots
find that the website is not easily
crawlable they will leave your website
and thus you may face a heavy loss in
indexing your pages it is considered to
be a good practice to submit sitemaps to
search engines some other technical
factors include having a less page load
speed meaningful page links having the
keyword with the page targets having
node dead or 404 pages and more let's
Now understand why one should have a
good knowledge of Google analytics and
Google Google search console tools to be
an SEO expert Google analytics and
search console Google analytics is a web
analytics service offered by Google it
was launched by Google back in 2005.
Google analytics generates various type
of reports and helps track bounce rates
identify the best content for your
website record user Behavior flow on
your site and many other mattresses
thereby allowing you to understand and
build your business strategies thereby
growing your business now that we have
understood why Google analytics is
essential let's understand about Google
search console search console priorly
known as Google webmaster tool monitors
the technicalities of the website so
suppose your website is not visible in
search results so there is a possibility
that search engine crawlers are unable
to crawl your website thus it is not
visible in search results to make
crawlers crawl your website you need to
optimize your website using search
console some other technical aspects
which makes search console more
important includes fixing indexing
problems sending the updated content or
Pages for re-indexing generating page
error reports generating alerts if there
are any indexing or other issues gets
the list of sites linking to your
website keep a track of mobile usability
amp pages and more some other tools
helpful in SEO are screaming frog which
works similar to search engine board sem
Rush is used for competitor analysis RFS
is used for backlink report generation
and more so let us know in the comment
section below out of the above tools
which one you are using for optimizing
your content so moving ahead with the
next Pro tip which is link building link
building helps in getting traffic as
well as trust in the eyes of search
engines getting backlink is one of the
important ranking factors thus getting
more and more backlinks helps the search
engines to understand that the quality
of your content is high and so other
websites are linking to your page which
also helps in getting more traffic and
high rankings having great link building
strategies will boost your career as an
SEO expert if you are not aware of
battling building strategies watch
videos on how to build backlink by
simply learn you can find and the link
in the description box below moving to
the tip number seven follow other SEO
experts for their strategies and stay
connected with SEO forum for recent
updates and discussions
search engines are continuously changing
so it is possible that the things that
are working now won't be working for
your web pages the next day thus it is
important to stay updated with what's
new with search engines following
experts under the same domain helps in
growth of skills so the question arises
how or where can you find these experts
well look for the SEO communities of
Google you can join various SEO Forums
on LinkedIn groups on Facebooks and
other q a and social media platforms
this not only helps in growth of skills
but it also keeps you updated with the
industry now speaking about another Pro
tip for being an excellent SEO
professional which is joining courses to
improve SEO skills there is a lot of
content developing each day on SEO and
so are the courses if you fail to
understand the SEO techniques or any
other related topics by the research
there are lots of free and paid courses
available across the web certifications
in any domain is always a plus point for
the career SEO techniques may not be
that fruitful at the very first time all
you need to do is have patience observe
what works for your content and what
doesn't learn from your observations
find new ways to put the improved
strategies on the table so that you get
the best out of your SEO practices so
these were the pro tips to become an SEO
expert
if you like this video share it with
your friends and family do subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
thanks for watching this video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here